i love this song vlad is still in
port-au-prince so we've got nikki
batiste filling in how are you nikki i'm
good good morning happy tuesday glad to
be here for vladwell he's doing
incredible reporting yeah it really is
incredible work here are a few stories
we think you'll be talking about today
starting with an animal handler in utah
who was attacked by an alligator during
a child's birthday celebration this
video is tough to watch but we're glad
to say that everyone is okay you can see
the handler lindsey bull open the door
to the enclosure the alligator lunges
forward and she pulls the animal back
then it suddenly snaps its mouth and her
hand gets caught in its grip she's then
dragged into the water a bystander
identified as donnie weissman rushes in
and jumps on the alligator's back look
at that after what feels like a long
tense few minutes bull is finally freed
from the alligator's grip she was taken
to the hospital but didn't have any
serious injuries weissman is also okay
and he's being praised for being so
brave unbelievable i'm looking at him
alone there i was thinking
she gets her out and then he's just sort
of left there with the alligator it's
hard to hear in the video here yeah it's
hard to hear but in the video the
handler is then instructing him on what
to do telling him to lie still and then
eventually jump off but i mean pretty
correct she's instructed him what to do
while he saved her and he sort of left
with the alligator yes my god and his
wife took the video it's his wife that's
his wife with a camera yes i wouldn't
even walk
no i would be fainting it's interesting
alligators are actually afraid of people
but apparently once you start feeding
them they see you as prey which of
course was her job
this also happened during a child's
birthday party they had taken the kids
there to you know have an experience
with the animals they got quite a shock
they got very very exciting it's a place
called scales and tails and the
alligator if you're wondering its name
is darth gator yes darth vader but
everybody's okay that's good everybody's
okay and in the makeup room a few people
are asking if the alligator is okay as
far as we know he is and apparently
lindsay said she still loves darth gator
all right